Fable 5 is officially back, and Tropic's
most powerful model. So, we actually
went ahead and we added in this model
onto Word Rocket. So, if you head over
to the generate content, and if you
scroll all the way down to testing with
the GLM 5.2 model, Claude Claude Fable 5
is now available for usage on Word
Rocket. So, I went ahead and I generated
some articles. Let's go ahead and take a
look at some of them. So, here's the
first article. If you watch my last
video, I actually went ahead and we did
a comparison between uh Claude Sonnet
and GLM 5.2. So, I'm actually going to
go ahead and copy over this article
here. We're going to use it in Neuron
Writer. So, this was the article that we
got back from Sonnet, I believe. We got
a 48.
So, let's go ahead and paste in the
article that we got back from Fable, and
let's see how Fable does.
So, Fable got a 55. So, as you can see,
the content was a little bit more
optimized, and it did a little bit
better than Claude um Sonnet, and even
uh GLM 5.2. So, here is the second
article about semaglutide
and BPC-157.
We're going to copy over this as well.
We're going to head back over to Neuron
Writer. So, this was the article. I
think we scored a As you can see, we got
a 75.
So, we scored a 75. I believe this was
with GLM. So, GLM scored a 75 out of
100. And let's see how
Claude Fable compares. So, Claude Fi-
Claude Fable got a 76. So, a little bit
better than what we were able to get
back from uh GLM 5.2, but obviously
there's going to be a little bit of a
price difference if you go ahead and
take a look at our pricing here. So,
Claude Fable costs about 60 cent per
article. So, that's obviously much much
more than what we would pay if we were
to use uh another model. So, this
article cost us 20 cent. Uh that other
article cost us 60. So, it just just
really depends on the length of the
article in which you're writing. So, it
can be between 60, I think that's on the
high end, and 20 cent per article. And
obviously, GLM and uh Claude Sonnet is a
lot less per article. If you want to see
my full comparison between GLM 5.2 and
Claude Sonnet, check out the latest
video that I just did. So, here's
another article that we wrote. Um just
from taking a look at the bird's-eye
view, it looks really, really good. We
get the key takeaways. Um we get the geo
fanout questions. We get the full
article. The images look great as well.
We get a FAQ, references. And then in
terms of our geo insights, we get a 90
out of 100. And for fanout questions, we
have 13 out of 14. For the keyword
cellulitis symptoms versus infected
cyst, we see that we scored a 63 out of
100 from Fable 5. That is the highest
optimization score for any
um article that's ranking for this
specific keyword. So, we see Fable 5
definitely writes really, really good
content. But when we take a look at the
pricing, it is a little bit more
pricier. So, it's definitely something
to consider if it's worth it. Maybe
there's certain pieces of content that
you can write using Fable 5, but for
your um bulk of your generation, you can
use a model like Claude Sonnet uh 4.6 or
Claude Sonnet 5, which is now available
also in Word Rocket. So, if you'd like
to try Claude Sonnet 5 or Claude Fable
5, you can try both of these models out
in Word Rocket. Just head over to
generate content, and we'll be adding in
Claude Sonnet 5 very, very soon. But as
you can see, you can find Claude Fable 5
and in the testing section. So,
essentially, you can try out any new
model as you like and see which one
works the best for your specific niche.
Hope that you guys enjoyed today's
video. I'll see you in the next one.
Take care.